[Musique]
dames et demoiselles messieurs voltaire
écrivait à à frédéric 2 qu'il faut toute
une vie pour maîtriser l'éloquence
approcher ce quelle éloquence mois si
j'en crois le timer qui est devant moi
j'ai 12 minutes 12 minutes pour vous
dire l'essentiel
d'abord de vous dire à l'instar de du
nom que porte cette intervention même
quand chacun d'entre nous quand chacun
d'entre vous il y a peut-être pas un
orateur mais vos autres orateurs
c'est une fausse croyance est une fausse
idée que de considérer que la parole est
l'apanage que de certains est que du
talent c'est tout l'inversé
et si je dis ça c'est pas dans un élan
de bienveillance singulier c'est par
pragmatisme
l'expérience n'a pas appris beaucoup de
choses même à les retenir une ou deux il
y as en chacun d'entre nous une capacité
oratoire
c'est le pragmatisme qui me fait parler
pas la bienveillance en chacun d'entre
vous en chacun d'entre nous il ya une
possibilité d'être bon à l'oral de
convaincre un auditoire et de convaincre
un public c'est juste là de l'autre côté
de la peur la formule n'y tienne est
vrai pour l'orateur deviens ce que tu es
devient capable de toi et c'est si vrai
que je vous dis ça d'entrée pourrait
être un bon orateur il faut il suffit et
cela prend du temps de l'engagement et
la discipline être vous même être
capable d'être vous même on se trompe
souvent à confondre éloquence et
grandiloquence on pense qu'être un bon
orateur c'est faire du théâtre à le
faire de l'exagération
c'est fondamentalement tools inverse
je demande néanmoins à ceux qui
regarderont cette intervention
bienveillance pour la raison excellente
qui me manque
moi là au moment où je vous parle
l'essentiel le fondement même de ce qui
fait un orateur un auditoire un public
c'est vraiment une caméra un caméraman
charmant au demeurant
mais c'est largement insuffisant vous
avez besoin de deux choses pour être
convaincant vous même et on me dit ouah
communiqué vient de communier il s'agit
d'abord d'un partage mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs si vous voulez
devenir un orateur n'écrivait pas vos
discours autre erreur fondamentale que
l'on fait on croit que une bonne
intervention orale c'est un bon discours
bien écrit prémédité prémâché à la
virgule près alors que c'est
fondamentalement tout l' inverse
n'écrivait pas vous discours ou en tout
cas ne lisez pas des discours parce que
écrire un discours intégralement rédigé
c'est la certitude de se priver de tout
ce qui fait l'éloquence c'est la
certitude de vous priver de l' échange
avec l'autre de cette communion de ce
partage
lorsque vous prendrez la parole lorsque
vous prenez la parole votre cerveau
reçoit des millions d'informations au
moment vous parler un regard même
masquer un visage une expression c'est
tout ça que vous recevez au moment vous
parlez qui fonde votre discours
la parole est fait pour moitié de celui
qui parle est pour moitié de celui qui
écoute sa demande le courage d'aller
regarder l'autre en face
mais la véritable éloquence de n'être
qu'à ce prix-là n'écrivait pas vous
discours depuis plusieurs années que
j'apprends et que je me nourris
d'éloquence
je prends à peu près dans toutes les
sciences celle du théâtre celle de l'art
scénique celle de l'éloquence judiciaire
celle des sciences cognitives
il y avait un immense orateurs qui était
un immense avocat qui s'appelait maurice
garçon jeune avocat prometteur orateur
il avait un autre maître son mentor qui
s'appelait laborie et voilà que lorsque
mauvaise garçon a eu sa première
plaidoirie aux assises à faire et ça
qu'un c'est que les assises c'est là où
vraiment l'avenir d'un homme peut se
jouer
il a montré son discours sa plaidoirie à
son maître son maître l'a regardé il va
donner l'approbation c'est un bon
discours il a pris et la déchirer devant
lui et il m'a dit 'maintenant plaide
parle ne lit pas ne lis jamais
avoir un discours intégralement écrit
c'est être en tête-à-tête avec vos
feuilles et voyez vous si vous restez
comme ça 80 % de votre intervention vous
vous coupez de l'essentiel alors vous
regardez de temps at de temps en temps
un auditoire mais voilà l'essentiel
c'est votre cuir chevelu
alors qu'il faut lui parler le prendre
avec il y à vaincre d'en convaincre il
faut aller vers lui n'écrivez pas ne
lisez pas des discours limitée personnes
le talent ne se prête pas aller à la
recherche de ce que vous êtes sculpta
propres statuts 10 et charpentier qui
était un immense orateurs qui a écrit
les remarques sur la parole alors me
direz vous c'est quoi que l'on proposait
ce l'improvisation
si je dois répondre oui je vous dirai
tout de suite comme disait vous jouez
que l'improvisation ne s'improvise pas
lorsqu'il s'agit de prendre la parole
il faut prémédité son improvisation
préparer un plan extrêmement clair le
plan c'est votre fils d'ariane votre
vade mecum vous savez vous vous partez
où vous allez et comment vous y allez
vous verrez apparaître quelque part ici
un petit papier où est mentionné les
étapes comme suivent l'exorde
l'argumentation et la péroraison
l'exorde c'est la captation de
bienveillance ça vaut pour toutes les
formes de discours que ce soit dans un
milieu professionnel que ce soit un
mariage où quelque chose d'un peu plus
gai un enterrement
il faut que votre première phrase donne
envie de vous suivre condamner les
phrases toutes faites
comme disait boileau que je solliciterai
sans peine à de nombreuses reprises dont
il est vrai que tout ce qu'il dit est
valable pour l'orateur inventer des
ressorts qui puisse ma tâche et que
votre première phrase est une invitation
à vous suivre
voyez moi j'ai commencé par voltaire
plutôt que juste un bonjour mesdames
bonjour messieurs bonjour les cas mr
l'argumentation ensuite l'argumentation
c'est ce que vous allez préparer
prémédité
avec acharnement il faut même parfois
sacrifier l'intelligence au profit de
l'intelligible si vous avez une
intervention à faire vous avez trois
grands arguments ils sont clairs sur
votre papier et dans votre esprit et ce
plan là vous devez le prendre et le
reprendre sans cesse
là encore nicolas boileau vingt fois sur
le métier remettez votre ouvrage police
et le sans cesse et leur police et
ajouter quelques fois mais souvent
effacé alors comment est-ce qu'on
prépare ce plan la grande erreur que
font les gens c'est de s'asseoir
lorsqu'ils ont un discours à préparer il
s'assoit ils prennent un stylo et une
feuille c'est la mort de l'art oratoire
c'est la mort de l'éloquence c'est dans
l'autre sens de l'oral à l'écrit pour
poser vos idées puis de l'écrit à l'oral
parler tout seul dans votre chambre dans
votre salon qu'importe parler tout seul
préparer votre intervention jacques
charpentier disais si vous voyez un
homme parler tout seul c'est soit un fou
soit un orateur soyez un orateur soyez
un orateur fou préparez votre
intervention à l'oral imaginez vous
prendre la parole mesdames messieurs
mesdemoiselles messieurs et vous
commencez ainsi à polir votre discours
et vous mettez sur le papier vos idées
l'argumentation dont puis la péroraison
la péroraison que l'on peut nommer aussi
conclusion c'est la petite touche sucrée
vous devez quitter votre auditoire sur
une touche sucrée sur une saveur sucrée
trouver une formule l'importance des
formules pour trouver des bonnes
formules c'est assez simple et assez
long et le temps qui m'est imparti ne me
suffira pas mais songez aux oxymore
aussonne et aux synonymes aux
allitérations aux oppositions
la parole n'est pas omnipotente mais
elle est omniprésente formule avec cette
idéologie tout compromettent une
compromission formule laisser votre
auditeurs et votre auditoire sur sa une
formule importante que vous sachiez
il est fondamental d'avoir ce plan mais
c'est une boussole pas un dictateur
oratoire il y aura toujours des imprévus
jouer de l'imprévu si vous faites un
bide assumez votre bide
s'il ya un bruit dans la salle jouée du
bruit dans la salle s'il ya un imprévu
comme la moi j'avais mesdames messieurs
un timer devant moi pour me dire qu'on
de temps j'ai jamais tant il me reste le
timer a disparu au lieu de ça j'ai des
images de poissons et d'océans qui
apparaît sur l'ordinateur donc le temps
me manque mais c'est pas grave je fais
avec
j'improvise et je peux improviser parce
que j'ai un plan clair donc n'écrivez
pas vos discours ne vous privez pas de
ce que vous donne l'auditoire jouer de
l'imprévu si un imprévu lire la peur de
la prise de parole en public
la peur voilà le grand sujet qui revient
voilà le grand sujet qui y vivent voilà
le grand sujet qui fait que à 24 heures
de certains concours d'éloquence des
candidats vous envoie un mail pour vous
dire j'ai peur j'y vais pas mesdames
messieurs
n'ayez pas peur de la peur il est plutôt
peur du jour où vous n'aurez pas peur de
prendre la parole en public
la peur que vous avez avant de prendre
la parole elle est salvatrice
c'est encore la modestie du souci de
bien faire et rien indispose davantage
qu'un homme pédant arrogant trop sûr de
sa science
l'auditoire a besoin d'une modestie
n'ayez pas peur de la peur une immense
actrice qui s'appelait sarah bernardt
qui donnait des cours de présence
scénique d'art oratoire d'expression
dramatique avait une élève qui lui a dit
moi madame je n'ai pas peur elle lui a
dit vous inquiétez pas ça viendra
lorsque vous aurez du talent mesdames
messieurs n'ayez jamais peur de la peur
conserver là tout ce qu'on peut faire
avec l'expérience en revanche c'est
d'appréhender différemment alors il ya
quelques méthodes pour ça là encore le
temps de manque pour tous de les donner
mais donnons les essentiels d'abord et
avant tout visualiser lorsque vous allez
prendre la parole visualiser
imaginez-vous moi j'ai longtemps imaginé
cette prise de parole la de ce soir je
l'imaginé exactement comme ça avec une
caméra qui me regardent avec des
lumières qui m'a bugs ça fait que je
suis moins surpris si vous maîtrisez
parfaitement votre plan votre anxiété
diminue à mesure de votre maîtrise du
plan ensuite aussi banal que cela puisse
paraître respirer les gens ont tendance
à oublier de respirer même avec un
masque entre le moment où vous donne la
parole au mans vous prenez la parole il
y aura toujours quelques secondes c'est
seconde là vous appartiennent prenez les
vous en voyez ici un message à tout
votre corps que ça va aller que vous
n'allez pas mourir que vous n'allez pas
disparaître et que même si vous vous
raté toute réussite n'est jamais qu'un
échec modifié alors n'ayez pas peur
et lorsque vous allez prendre la parole
réplique réfléchissez
respirez profondément ensuite de quoi il
ya également la position qui est
importante
je ne sais pas si on voit l'entièreté de
mon corps mais mesdames messieurs les
gens qui vont commencer à parler qui
sont quasiment en position religieuse
celle ci pose problème
il faut avoir un espace des jambes
suffisamment important mon professeur de
rhétorique me disait si tu veux
entraîner à une bonne position
tu prends le métro tu mets entre les
deux rames les mains derrière le dos et
si tu n'es pas tomber entre les deux et
trois stations sais que tu es sur la
bonne voie être bien ancrés au sol
cristiano ronaldo avant tirer un
coup-franc fondamentalement ancrée vous
bien noces ensuite il ya un contact avec
la matière vous aurez normalement
normalement un pupitre devant vous dans
la plupart des cas vous me direz y en a
pas mais dans la plupart des cas vous
aurez un pupitre touché le pupitre
touché la chaise ne vous va si c'est pas
dessus mais ayez un contact avec la
matière la matière rassure infiniment
ensuite mesdames messieurs comment on
fait pour ne pas avoir cette angoisse du
blanc cette angoisse de tomber cette
angoisse des mots qui ne viennent pas
cette angoisse des mots qui
disparaissent et bien ce point
fondamental qu'on ne dit pas assez
les mots je peux faire des dizaines de
master class et vous entendez les gens
vous parler de la position
comment vous tenir droit attention à la
main droite qui doit pas dépasser la
main gauche
mais il est une chose et personne ne
vous parle de l'essentiel les mots votre
vocabulaire
l'erreur fondamentale est de croire que
les dictionnaires sont faits pour les
jeunes années donnez-vous comme objectif
5 mo par semaine apprenez 5 mo par
semaine l'éloquence l'art oratoire c'est
quoi c'est la certitude la confiance
dans ses moyens de langage d'aller
trouver le mot juste au bon moment la
bonne nuance le bon trait et vous êtes
limités nous sommes limités par une
seule chose
notre aptitude à penser et donc notre
aptitude à dire plus autre champ de
penser et large c'est que votre
vocabulaire s'est élargi
vous ne pouvez pas nommer ce que vous
pouvez pas penser
alors mesdames messieurs
donnez vous rendez vous avec vous même
ce dimanche matin quel autre jour pour
avoir plus de vocabulaire
je finis sur deux points très importants
le rythme dans votre discours vous
pouvez écouter les dizaine d'orateurs
qui vont rester monocorde monotone du
début à la fin
varier les rythmes variés les tons
variés même le fond heureux qui
dansaient versé d'une voix légère passer
du duo grave du plaisant aux sévères et
n'ayez jamais peur de ceux ci le silence
les gens confondent les blancs et les
silences si vous prenez la parole il n'y
a rien de pire disait sénèque qu'un
torrent de parole qui ne s'interrompt
pas n'ayez pas peur du silence au même
titre que vous ne devez pas avoir peur
de la parole vivez votre silence le
petit silence qui précède la parole ça
fait partie de votre parole celui-ci
prenez le et vivait mesdames messieurs
comme je vous disais il faut toute une
vie pour véritablement approché
éloquence mais si vous retenez
l'essentiel de ne pas lire vos discours
jamais de ne pas chercher à imiter
quelqu'un d'autre de ne pas chercher la
théâtralité de ne pas chercher la
grandiloquence de ne pas avoir peur de
la peur alors déjà en quelques minutes
vous aurez retenu probablement
l'essentiel est pour vous dire ceci pour
clore quelques phrases de sacha guitry
qui reprennent à peu près toutes ces
idées là alors elles sont normalement
pour le comédien mais elles valent pour
tout à chacun et pour toute personne qui
veut prendre la parole il s'adresse aux
comédiens et lui dit ceci as tu peur as
tu peur de paraître en public ce soir
oui papa j'ai peur j'ai très peur ça
c'est bon c'est très bon c'est un
artiste s'il a peur il a compris c'est
très bon mais tout de même attention
comprenez-moi bien ce n'est qu'une
précaution soit agité nerveux et soit le
follement
mais dans sa loge seulement que le
public ne voit jamais la mémoire
indécise le souci d'être bon la peur
d'être mauvais ne copie pas les gestes
que l'on fait tous les gestes sont bons
quand ils sont naturels ce qu'on apprend
sont toujours faux si tu peux fait rire
le public
en tout cas d'ici peu son ennui et s'il
te méprise ou t'oublie sitôt qu'il a
passé la porte
valles le ça ne fait rien on oublie
toujours ceux qui nous ont fait du bien
merci beaucoup
[Musique]